jean-luc I just realized that I turn the
volume down when there was no volume
coming through from the game anyway what
up everyone it's Friday happy Friday
uh I hope you've all had a wonderful
week and I'm glad that you're all here
to watch us continue our adventure
through playing all of the Mortal Kombat
games before moral Kombat eleven comes
out next week so stoked so excited but
yeah Jenna look how are you doing I'm
doing okay
tired oh I feel that I'm doing a very
good job I'm excited to be here I feel
like I'm a walking corpse but cuz you
know why cuz we're playing hit a bend oh
no oh no we're playing Mortal Kombat vs.
DC Universe
we're probably have to move that camera
so that's okay perhaps the weirdest
crossover I one of the worries crossover
as I can think of no anyone can think of
a weirder crossover please let me know
because I want I want to know that yeah
right
oh look at the bet oh so this is my
favorite thing go through the menus like
just pick random like going to options
extras it like follows through this
weird like going all over the place
thing so go back and then you go back
into options you go out is it just
Batman scorpions so weird sometimes if
you load into BIOS of just takes you
where the controller how do I fight you
right there how I fight you John Luke so
we're gonna we're gonna play three games
today we're gonna play this one we're
gonna play nine then we're gonna play
some X yeah cuz we're leading up to MK
11 next week 11 a.m. what happened John
Luke oh nothing uh nothing happen this
morning just like general long week yeah
it's it's been a heck of a time being
tired too player do some fights
maybe excuse me might be dying what
maybe we can just leave the camera down
there well I don't think it covers up
anything other than like a meter will
save but if people want us to move it we
can move it
okay but all these characters I feel
like we should do one of us should pick
em K one of us should pick do you see
the spirit of the spirit of givers DC
which side do you want to take I'll take
em K I guess alright we can swap we must
celebrate
Joker being in Smash by picking Joker
okay I'll play game scorpion because I
know this is perfect so I was gonna say
I really think that Joker's actually
done pretty well in this game I like how
silly he is Sheldon mopes just we
already did Shaolin monks a little yeah
we've been going through all of them
so if you want to check back through the
history of videos you can you can see
that but uh I kinda want to do like a
playthrough that I'm still thinking
about it
that's the lasting effect alright so
that's the other thing about this game
is it doesn't have like oh here we go
can you find it doesn't have like proper
fatalities at all it's got rock paper
scissors yeah I'm mashing that button I
beat you up
so I actually played like a fair amount
of this and I'm having a real fun time
remembering how it works I never played
this one this action I like second time
buying it oh shoot there we go giddy
okay that's not how you do is put in
there now I'm good that's like okay are
you are you sure though ah he's got he's
got palms there we go that's the classic
we only get an air combat you just knock
you down all the way oh I love that were
in the Batcave - Joker wins so we didn't
use any of our energy stuff one of those
types of weeks I get it yeah so that
that little like runaway thing that he
does love that so much
I'm out here with that yeah yeah yeah
whoo I'm slowly remembering like all of
his moves and that's a thing
sure let me do that right away confetti
it's so nice
anyone else know having a leg is is it
lagging we're not well we're not
dropping frames try lowering your
resolution gray fox or maybe refreshing
might be a thing on YouTube son but
you're else which I'll do I'll do a
Batman all right all right
oh I'll go with buck keno sure you know
the fight I've I've always been waiting
for so who would win in a fight Kano or
Batman that age-old question we'll
settle it here need retro compatibility
for mk9 the pc version of MK 9 is pretty
good I don't think you need like a like
a strong system to run it but also just
yet bringing it back in general will
probably be really cool
okay no balls on deck Batman uppercuts
oh my gosh that man you can't believe it
shoot that's that's like an arc on
Arkham Asylum combo flippy get out of
here with that this is crap yeah MK vs.
DC was a notic great game I used to kind
of feel like I was alright won't be on
his planet right now I think a lot of
people liked it at the time just cuz it
it was a Mortal Kombat game but those
Mortal Kombat game that it was starting
to kind of return to the classic move
Jetson style I think like people who
were itching for that we're all sort of
like oh man yeah like they're kind of
starting to like go back to the basics
but then it's also got this weird DC
stuff in it I kind of so it wasn't like
the bulb returned people were really
wanting
oh god pause oh no I can't pause this
this is the most hardcore Mortal Kombat
game because you can't pause to check
fatality what is that no way you gonna
be all the pies right maybe I maybe I
had to hold it I think maybe you can do
it in the middle of the fight but you
can't do it in the like furnished room
uh you see my game so there there's some
pretty pretty fun stuff going on with it
ah Deadpool favorite character nothing
this is a bad game by any means but I do
think it uh it's a bit lacking compared
to other Mortal Kombat so if you have
any like the staples you really look for
like the crypts um I'm also not really
into the character designs no and some
of these designs did kind of carry over
to 9 like so many play looks pretty
similar and which is you also were
saying you're not really a fan of some
of the character designs and 9 I I don't
like some of the costume design a 9 I
like the way that a lot of the
characters start style
yeah I like the art style a 9 but yes on
the costume designs blue I remember that
nice I bet you if I still like we're
called some of the combos for this like
I I probably be having a just a good
time still I'm sort of pulling it back
don't have John Cage I know box night
what am I gonna do I have to wait until
we get into nine to get my Johnny Cage
fix
[Music]
I'm not really sure what I'm doing there
but so you gotta like you gotta I don't
attend it and I don't think it did good
because it's like oh they're gonna hit
with X so I'm gonna dodge X that was not
a uppercut oh shoot
sure you're right another thing also I
like this is one of those really good
examples of a stage that's just kind of
merged yeah look down the middle
I like that like Shang Tsung's temple
vote mixed with the island for all the
Amazonians Amazonian Islands the Amazon
Island Amazon's Island calm try to
remember what what it is to enhance of
their mind in a rage okay that was an
interesting move in general cabal was
number one I believe it cabal is really
fun in 9 here recently how I had been
was saying how he wants to do like a
Marvel fighting game not like a Marvel
versus you know comic just or or a
Marvel versus he would like to do a
Marvel DC fighting game he was like dude
I would love to do that and I was like
yeah dude take it I'd play that I think
that'd be pretty good healthy uh touches
am was this is the first place Sascha's
am really was in this game cuz I'd never
heard of him up until that point talked
to good ol Phil Spencer hey we need we
need that MK 9 on our Xbox ones yeah I
really do it was such a like there's so
much in that game
cat cheese
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
feel like I knock you off I did so I I
knew that you're gonna hit X so I hit X
to counter oh so it's all it's all like
rock paper scissors nonsense
yeah that's I'm glad that that system
kind of got left behind
I'll get that sweep also I I think the
inputs aren't like this because I'm
doing like half service and stuffs
coming out but when I'm doing other
segments I mean I was able to do like
back back to do like the spear oh yeah
it's just me my big dumb thumb was
hitting multiple buttons you're also
using 360 d-pad that's very true
I see you've also found your rage button
damn
[Music]
the ultimate fatality no uh MKX Mobile
is og I used to actually play a bit of
it just so I can get the costumes should
probably check it out for 411 right
Gustav is including a free copy of em
can with pressures of MK 11 well the
whole thing is it's not backwards
compatible yeah right now so otherwise
they probably would do that
I imagine I'll even I'll do Shazam
because this is all do Isis a cannonball
sick we nailed it
oh I can't like it it was worse than cuz
he comes out as a kid and it yells
Shazam he turns into a superhero and
never and then Raiden beats him up he
murders a child I can't believe it
riddens not how is Raiden like a good
guy is really a good guy busy yeah so I
know this stage has this if I can
actually get you a little left here
you can actually like run through [ __ ]
this it's a thing they do that like a
justice yeah there you like this yeah
that's a new Oh have you guys seen the
new character model for the Yaquis of
Kathleen judge man yeah that's pretty
good
apparently it's an original not based on
anyone's face it's weird cuz it looks
like a person looks like pretty good
oh they're gonna bloody like they're all
beaten up and yeah I think this is when
they also started doing like the weird
paddle down let's do it again
Wow
Geico nice oh I thought I was I was
losing the tap I'm like oh my god John
Luke is killing me now it should be down
up look I get like you do back for day I
feel like we've got a horse that's how
you do it it's back forward and backward
a now it's down back okay cuz I want to
see her at your you're flying move I
want to hear him yell thought was on
it's a tell one of these things well
here we go yeah we can you actually
traveling well my energy teleport the
Superman Ford Ford be eventually can all
the Superman yeah yeah they can't
believe they changed the name anyway
we're going back over here that's my
signature fatality from now on can't
believe Captain Marvel punch that Elder
God in the crotch love to make this game
best available yeah I'd be okay if they
skip this one for backwards
compatibility and gave us nine I mean I
love every game to be backwards
compatible yeah for archival purposes
but if I had to pick one he definitely
would pick nine let's do it Liu Kang
something that works pretty good this
one the strokes a pretty cool guy he's
got guns and isn't afraid of anything oh
yeah that's right the story mode for
this game is a mess it's just wait this
this game did Smash Brothers story
before Smash Brothers in Smash Brothers
story what I mean well because the whole
thing is everyone is infected with rage
and silliness Oh everyone's infected
with something giving you the excuse to
fight against everyone else like why
would Raiden beat up Superman that's why
yeah and that also explains why the
superheroes don't murder normal people
breakers going on it's where they had
that whole thing in a injustice where
it's like they all took a pill that
makes them as powerful a Superman would
you like their way of explaining how all
these like characters can be on equal
terms I think they didn't even do that
for injustice to I think they just gave
up on that as a premise yeah maybe they
maybe they did keep it but I don't
remember them making a big deal out of
it if they did who Kings still pretty
good we got your sword out now I just
uppercut you while holding my sword I
mean you know like you do
yeah I'm I'm kind of curious about the
like they kind of left the battle damage
thing behind after nine yeah liked em
didn't have it so much either just got
really bloody and that was about it
really bloody and really sweaty you
haven't liked night you'd see like their
grain and yeah like maybe maybe that's
the biggest mistake fighting names have
made as they've gone autos but they're
like you know we had sweat tech yeah
into the sweat stuff seemed do you
always embraced it pull-on I mean if you
want to like embrace it maybe it can
work but sweat just looks kind of
unnatural and weird I don't really care
for it it's really hard to do right I'm
like if you can't do it right I don't
think you should I just think you
shouldn't do it yeah but like it doesn't
look it doesn't look good my MKX
what we can talk about that when we get
to it I guess yeah go on this one I'm
gonna be honest I was kind of checked
out maybe like five minutes ago
it's fair I've been like oh man I'm
definitely avoiding the characters that
I don't want to play too much play I am
very excited for MK 9 we do one more
fight it's not over dudes want to do a
the scorpion sub-zero fight sure yeah
screw it TC what are you talking about
get her out of here I'm only here from
Mortal Kombat I'm just here for Mortal
Kombat's so I feel like we have to do
one one fight with scorpion sub-zero
every game also I kind of like his
design in this where he's got like the
or sub-zero because he's got like the
actual ice arms yeah in the Batcave here
we go just like we imagined it as the
prophecy foretold their final duel
one of these days I'll and my my
scorpion spear hey hello okay sup sir
cannot normally do that the Sub Zero has
got some really cool ice powers through
the through the ages
[Music]
the possibilities for what scorpion can
do is video game you're wiping the floor
of me that's the kick combo I'm looking
for right you got to look at this
fatality and do it alright I'll see what
I can do is it is it in the move list do
we know that super moves I'll fire no
it's not they're not good in this game
anyway guys got that side
I know attention so the manager saw
words behind you nothing personal kid oh
no not the bat-computer yeah I switched
it around in the very last part that's
awful
we have scorpions like skulls hanging
out right now good even though people
are disappointed with how not violent it
was they kind of pushed the team rating
a decent amount I feel like yeah it's
all about comedic timing and deliver
really is it really is all right MK 9 MK
9 yeah let's move over to MK 9 I'm gonna
switch the camera over so we can yeah so
we have to do a whole bunch of weird
switching what with controllers and
wires because we're actually this is a
three console episode we're playing MK
vs. DC on the 360 m MK 9 on the PC and
then MK X on the ps4 so John Luke is is
being a cable wizard and just hooking
everything up while I sit here in stall
for time but ya know Shaolin monks well
we played Shaolin monks before and I'm
gonna be honest I'm kind of thinking
like what if we did a whole playthrough
of it at some point but I don't know
that's kind of a weird thing to do
randomly out of nowhere but it was
really fun it's a very good game all
right I'm gonna start it up sort of done
I have to use the bathroom okay sorry
about that no no you're good drank a lot
of coffee that's right I'll hang out
with everyone it was a good time I could
jump into the game I could do stuff it's
it's all good a cable wizard with a K oh
we're getting ready for MK 11 by playing
all of the the previous games in the
series
it's started Rinne we're up
special-forces playthrough we played
maybe like 30 minutes of Special Forces
before we're like it's not as bad as
mythology sub zero though that game has
not aged to make it any better but
that's not how that game should work
pardon me for a second
cool optimal settings this may take a
minute screen might flash I'll be
prepared high very high sounds good
let's just keep it I just want to get
into star fighting cool let me out let
me out so what do we got here I'm gonna
do one of my favorite things with John
Luke not being here test your luck and
it's a thing I wish that would come back
and it hasn't yet and of course I'll
play Johnny Cage who else booked the day
off of work on Tuesday I I mean I'm I'm
probably not gonna take the day off
but anyway so test your luck one of my
favorite things it just lets you
basically do a roulette just do like a
fun random game sorry now we've got
Shiva can't jump Health's gonna drop
into the field and we have infinite
super meter and it just lets you have
like a whole bunch of fun random like
modifiers
and I got the the counter off right from
the beginning it's just like I planned
it
what a time to come back in alright I
just walked in i saw Johnny Cage nut
punch just do another one for kicks tops
on em k story mode trailer oh I love it
that launch trailer was sick yeah are
you doing the tower no this is just test
your your luck hit me Shiva hit me it's
pretty good
Johnny Cage wins anyway yeah we can we
get back out I was just doing my it's
really good let's do your you're in
control now or am I in controller there
we go
I think I jumped into player 1 that's
okay a lot of really cool characters in
this game too and I wish would show up
again yeah the it's like all the classic
characters from the first three games
which is great
I don't even know why I'm pretending I
got a aged striker I say you gotta
strike her uh said yeah the launch
trailer also showed a whole bunch of
other characters that I don't know
what's going on with that oh they sure
like didn't they show like sectaurs
sector cyrex I don't know the some of
the the robot boys iraq's yeah they
showed definitely definitely cyrex
they definitely showed Cyrax and I think
they also showed a side door
but also more importantly than that they
remix the movie theme and I want dead so
app it's very good yeah my guess is the
cuz the list the character was spirits
confirmed right at this point like
there's not really anything I think new
so I if I had a guess
they are like story mode characters the
way like Sindel was yeah
and in 10 wasn't like that we had those
two spots at the top of the roster
though don't know what's going on there
I mean they could be hopefully it'll be
DLC I'm sure one of them she'll calm
though oh yeah they've shown the
gameplay trailer room but they have oh
sure sure yeah have a grenade eagle
sound it is now canonically I don't have
a grenade but I have gross I have boy
GUI balls that Thanks dang it
come on fall for that say after I
spammed it against Cheever earlier
there's no no way oh god damn oh I have
to I have to do it so mrs. rain drain
would be really cool you can get Frost
in the story mode I heard there was a
leak the rest of leaked yeah frost leaks
okay
we're already Rorion on it we're already
doing it it's already happening I also
really like just the way I like the way
this game looks yeah like it's it's
violent but like looking at it now it
seems like it's just like cartoonish
yeah I mean that's kind of what they've
always been I go for a boon it said
they've never wanted it to be realistic
just gusting yeah yeah just real gross
looking cyrex actually I really like his
I'll do all the sectoral and you can
pick like he's like pre cyber you know
my costume I like that stuff like they
added a lot of like cool cool lore I
really like the Mortal commerce you can
also just get the classic one - yeah
where it just looks like hockey pads
it's just a whole bunch of cool oh if I
have to so that's also an intro that
makes sense in Mortal Kombat to say I'll
kill you if I have to
so trying to remember what the Missile
Command is got me at my fire Cyrax is
definitely my favorite or two robot boys
though
yikes
oh you got yours off do you try do they
literally define at the same time great
nice look at that dragon in the
background this game still holds up
really well - it does it plays really
nice I think the only thing about it
that doesn't aged particularly well is
the UI it looks a little pixel Eve on a
shoot higher resolutions like we're just
playing it at a 1080p and because all
the UI is made for 720 those uh all the
pre-rendered cutscenes the definition on
PC they look Oh like that bitrate you
can see the pixels it looks dang it
doesn't look great that's something
where I'm like I would really I would
just be like hey clean up the UI and
then like just re-encode those cutscenes
and like yeah an ad or 4k or whatever yo
so good good oh I need I don't need you
to like really redo the graphics we're
doing I got a I got a player's noob
saibot I'll do a smoke then where
there's smoke there's fire
oh yes the hair is still something else
I'm sorry somebody a while ago mentioned
rain so we should pick rain okay I'll
see box nights mentioning cyber sub-zero
there's fire there it is yeah this hair
looks more droopy than I remember it was
very emo
I think about a noobs new design he's
very like grim reaper looking in 11 more
importantly than his design yeah like
I'm okay with his design I'm sure he's
got some cool gear stuff ways his voice
sounds like dr. claw and I can't yeah
it's pretty I can't
he's very emo yeah shrine there we go so
I remember I remember that combo that I
used to do all the time I'm glad that
just something works
oh you mind we both did at the same time
again we got to go in I can't believe it
vomit noob is really cool
John we versus MK 9 is the best roster
of any mortal kombat it's pretty good
how do I really have to think about
what's the best roster I'd I also I
really like em canines just the way it
plays it plays really nice I definitely
prefer it's slower pace yes 10 I know
some people really like the wait 10
plays and we're like disappointed in the
way 11 kind of plays how it's slower but
I like because it's closer to 9 same
it's like that that makes me feel cool
doing that again it's not even that
flashy a combo what just happened
spam that teleport that's not what
that's my mistake is I'm not spamming
his teleport I gotta look it up because
I'm I'm lame but let's let's do it
anyway I'll make a wish
he gets his MK mask that's cool oh he
does that's neat oh that's good to know
yeah I'm the cosmetic stuff I think is
uh I'm really excited to see all the
options is it like mid it's supposed to
be jump arrange so I was trying to feel
it out yeah they kind of go didn't they
get rid of the jump stuff and yeah jump
is kind of not a good cuz the jump
stuffs weird same with mid it's always
like what it what defines mid yeah we're
like sweet
well this sweep was always a tough one
yeah yeah sweet it's hoop was easy for
me when someone's like ah the ranges
that you could do like your sweep attack
and I'm like there's one thing I know
how to do its sweep or it's uppercut so
well jump is like the way I would always
get it is you go right in front of them
and then you jump back yeah and that's
where you want to be the like you know
figuring that out it can that's work
yeah I bought I botched the fatality oh
yeah there's rain like rain I forgot I'm
the worst goes combat codes I'd skip the
intro it's no good
just up and down hey see my cool trick
hey well see some cool oh now I get to
do my trick ok just teleport really
quick you and your Mac I like him a lot
like what's let's give up ah man it's a
big mistake the bummer or max great yeah
what are characters that aren't in 11
that people are really Melina people is
very upset about me I did notice that a
lot of people are upset about Melina and
the fact that like katanas got some of
Molina's moves everyone's like well
Melina is not gonna they're not they're
not gonna put him in yeah yeah you're so
did the same way people were
disappointed about no Jayde
yeah and x/y the gene is back though
yeah she looks cool I didn't I didn't
play that other beta so I didn't really
mess with her
I never miss to the combat code on the
verse spring was it due so you put input
different codes and it can activate
different things like hey everyone's got
big heads jig heads or just calm yeah
and let's combat or you know you're you
can do x-rays all the time
god damn I'm not playing well today it's
ok I'm also picking the characters that
I'm like I remember how to do a thing
with them sort of and I'm like someone
asked for rain I'll play rain I'll play
the puddle know how to play them uh all
these are from you know what varies
that's there's Nina staged fatalities
definitely not a fatality power forward
stood let's do that one
there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah
I hate the fact that in my mind I'm like
buzz kind of team look that man just
ripped better all of his limbs off and
then crushed his head underneath the
weight of his own body and I'm like you
tried I guess anyone else has fur for
any other ones or can I just go with
whoever reptile someone asked for
reptile oh hell yeah almost he keep
going with the classic costumes some
horrible it is weird that there's no
reptile though yeah it's another one
that's uh yeah yeah people are saying
upset there's no reptile no smoke I was
really hoping for smoke because he
wasn't in ten else's they'll bring smoke
back yeah yeah smoke back either so if I
remember one thing about reptiles got
that slide yeah names got it it's got a
dash
[Music]
can we have match with Freddy sure oh
heck yeah he's a he's an interesting
character I never really was big up on
him though okay it's sick teleport I got
so I like I like how the robot teleports
usually come in with them like falling
apart and rebuilding themselves like
destruct themselves yeah yeah poke him
in the eyes spin his head hurts give him
the boot
oh no okay I had to cheap that one out a
bit
scorpion vs Sub Zero I think that that's
what we do when we're about to switch
the game that'll be like though the last
one we do that's that's the classic with
a kid
yep let me just slide right up into your
your sweep zone sweetness get right up
into the into sweet zone of the eye poke
dang do this again
mm-hmm that that that uh author hole in
sweeper range for Ford
down up down down for back yeah
Kung Lao vs Liu Kang we do that no
that's fine I love how his face masks on
yeah I can only human face and he's like
nah that was show just guys I love it
I'm really a reptile boy I'm actually a
reptile you all thought that it was just
a cool name
smoke versus new black charity smoke
versus me um I'll do Freddie okay and
then afterwards we'll do a conga versus
Liu Kang's love you like
those are some P versus EC we just got
done with MK vs. DC and we've moved on
to Mortal Kombat 9 and then later on
we'll move over to 10 and then dang 11s
out next week yeah I'm very excited like
it's kind of weird in that like playing
through all these games is like normally
I'd be like oh yeah Mortal Kombat 11 I'm
really excited but I'm like doubly
excited now because we've been playing
so much Mortal Kombat so it's been like
a like a good thing but also kind of
like a real rough thing oh no murdered
hey I shouldn't even I need to do that
other ways no we're here for the
spectacle of it I think you're picking
Freddy anytime I just hope I'm able to
do some cool stuff with him for it
should be my gamertag what was that what
should be my gamertag
Oh gotta depend on that super armor this
is the complete edition for PC
oh I have I have to do a grab with them
of course
dang on those tanks trying to try to get
those those cool cool fan servicing
moments
oh no wait he's got a ranged reptile boy
as you might get respect
there's something about what I'm gonna
do for my PSN name I actually had a
really weird dream the other night where
I actually like dreamt but I changed my
PSN name weird to something that I don't
know like I was I was upset that it
actually worked but at the same time I
was kinda like okay this is fine they
let me do it and I'm kind of I wouldn't
actually do the name in real life oh
dang I was like I stand I sense the
winds were shifting
oh no how you gonna do it man just gonna
take it up all its mid mid hit what a
rush
Annie Ford back down down oh just one
more one more time just to make sure hey
in the right button you sure
hit in the right button oh boy Brad down
down there hey gal I just had to add to
recenter why no that's a lot of blood
I also missed the like bloody font for
fatalities you know yeah
learning and headed me through mortal
kombat it's a heck of a thing look okay
if there's one thing that I do very well
it's choke so okay so we do Kung Lao and
okay we're comfortable with so I feel
like we should do our Shaolin monk
character so I was I was asking law and
you were kratos please I wish we could
but we don't have that version right
I actually own at home I was the version
I originally bought
show me what you can do you've got it
Liu Kang mainly keep telling us to
pre-order for Shao Kahn but he's been in
Mortal Kombat 9 the whole time just
chilling in his chair can't blame him
though yeah c'mon man I guess dang dang
dang I'm remembering how to play Kung
Lao it's happening got that really
strong fingertip poke oh my hat's baby
what are you doing now remember fiendish
outcome in story mode yeah he sucks yeah
he was not fun geez geez geez oh no it's
over
dude you got home I got downloaded it's
it's the site like Kung Lao it I like
kung a lot a lot yeah he's a cool dude I
like his hat which just can you give it
a mix Evan given stage fatality or babe
ality we could pick one with the stage
fatality that we have sweep range a done
down Ford back it's a little bit closer
there we go nailed it oh it's the one oh
no how could you do it he's your best
friend I can't believe this
Real Talk that's that's one of the ones
that sticks out that's that's a
memorable one that one sticks out in the
new one where they split him in like a
wishbone
yeah don't remember babe a letís I think
they're they're hidden I'm not yeah did
you guys play the story I played it back
when it came out yeah
anonymous dream though let's do like two
more fights two more and then I kinda
want to go over to X yeah I'm down um
I'll pick Shiva because she hasn't shown
up in a game for two games
I'll pick and then we can we can finish
it with Sub Zero and scorpion yeah
everyone what's your favorite move with
Shiva it's it's down up it's just it's
just one day it'll happen come on we'll
get there you just down up down up all
the time doesn't matter it doesn't mat
out of here I see the only way to
appropriately respond to that completely
oh boy oh she's a fireball - I forgot oh
stop on the girl so it's this fun fact
at MK 9 character select screen the too
far from each other our rivals how
interesting you always do something
really cool with their characters like I
was talking about that earlier this week
about how like like pick pick the
character select screen for Mk
oh she have the overhead thought oh
that's plush hit the overhead smash
thing that Goro has just got trip though
oh no oh no
oh really
there's no recovery on that holy cow
that is stupid do you that is a reason I
am putting a game I thought she was free
all right talking about oh man and like
scratch my head and pause at the same
time does not work okay you guys are
scrubs
hey but we're having a good time so you
know how much I care it's not a lot full
screen all right I'm pretty close to
that already heck yeah up up up up down
forward okay yeah uh not moral combat
professionals as a disclaimer we're here
for the fun of it just kind of like I
guess yeah you cut another person's head
off I guess that's cool I guess
all right so now now we gotta do
scorpion sub-zero to bring into our
journey do you want scorpion sub-zero
I'll take
I think scorpion alright how you want
classic costume some attitude you got a
pop up sometimes you know it's Mortal
Kombat by me in the in the streets fight
you win 11 I do kind of like scorpions
designing this a lot though cuz he he's
got more of the scorpion look to him
thanks said that's why you didn't like
it I think I think I've warmed up to it
since the week ago last week when you
said that see I think the problem was
when I said that I was looking at his I
don't like his weapons I like his out I
don't like that he has like scorpion
tails for hilts yeah it's kind of a bit
much everything else everything else is
good we can keep that Maggie's got a
hood oh yeah we got it we got cold
swords
I don't know why I did that I was
walking I was blocking you also
literally had no health and I still did
it anyway yeah there might be a one what
it was maybe it shipped through I
probably did so there was one game where
sub Z was able to be like a slide and he
was able to kind of like like meter burn
it ended like a thing where we turn
around
maybe that's ten cuz it's not it's not
happening here yeah if you can't do it
here it's probably ten
okay that was a good one yeah man I've
got to bring us into a third round I
can't I can't let you shut me out okay
you can see my skull yeah man
there's just a lot of oh no I haven't
thrown a single ice ball yet got clones
that's that's okay I can't enhance the
UH or maybe I'm trying to Detroit
trigger but it's now I think I can
enhance the spear yeah which I believe
you can do in ten crazy I know you can
do it in 11 or you couldn't Aveda me
that's why I'm thinking of the beta for
11
these are Mortal Kombat physics at their
their strongest oh my finish what all
right and we I mean finishing with the
scorpion fatality is pretty is a very
good way to do it okay
split decision around oh you got your
toasties the the throwback one right I
think so what should I do
down up ups are kind of gonna do get
real close and just for boardwalk yeah
back forward back okay yeah oh yeah that
was pretty good yeah that one portal
combat never forget before combat day I
forgot that was a thing I did not
remember it all the time sweet all right
let's do the last change as we jump over
to the PlayStation you'll have to watch
row it's the main menu there and we
fight in real life yeah that's how
that's the next thing I'm gonna dress up
a scorpion you're actually faced off in
a real Mortal Kombat tournament I hope
you guys are ready for it oh yeah that's
the thing I'll never forget is that a
portal and Mortal Kombat 9 came out on
the same day portal 2 and I was at like
a 24 hour livestream at high voltage for
the launch of conduit - yeah and I had
to sit there and talk about how I was
excited for the conduit - to come out
when I was only thinking about portal 2
and Mortal Kombat the whole time it was
rough Oh conduit Tuesday good game
though but not it's not like my me again
that's a hell of an ending I'll tell you
that yeah yeah have you ever beaten no I
know at the end of that game Abraham
Lincoln jumps through a time portal and
it's like we have to save the future
never mind maybe conduits
a way better game and we should all play
conduit something like that yeah I
definitely something about Abraham
Lincoln to jump through a time portal
and that was like their post-credit
cliffhanger and I was like they'll never
make a third one but hell yeah yeah
bring a beanie again yeah it's like a
thing I do a lot is wear beanies that's
alright sometimes you just got get messy
here John Luke today man yeah apparently
we unplugged their PlayStation fours the
wrong way so it's upset at us and now
it's checking our memory to see if it's
okay
woops so you're you're sucking out with
us for a bit place Shrek first do you
still have that Shrek Shrek game in here
somewhere is it still on the desk no
that's at my desk
Oh sort of folded into the personal
collection yeah it's part of my personal
collection uh yeah means Johnny Cage
heck yeah
Johnny Johnny Cage is where it's at who
are you gonna mane and I'm Kate Lebanon
I don't know I want to mess with all the
characters I I am definitely because
I've got a do Johnny Cage
Johnny Cage I'm interested in him I'm
interested in Cassie Cassie looks cool
I actually really like how Jax looks now
- yeah Kung Lao is a good staple for me
I do like I hate the character Kano
but I like playing Kano yeah and for
some reason I can actually do all right
with him usually when I play as him and
I always have like a weird pocket Kay no
but yeah can we have Leatherface yeah
well I won't have all the DLC Kirk as
much as we can you know we should be
good
favourite MK 11 character come back I'm
just glad Johnny cages in there
[Music]
but I guess surprise wise ah it's all
mine the persona music I mean but do
mind the persona music this over here
for yeah yeah I love that it's still
playing the music and the more comment
look up sup well I'm just gonna this is
what we're experiencing right now it's
very good it was really good play me and
Mortal Kombat 11 Hey community Fridays
next week that's the plan if you want to
fight us in Mortal Kombat 11 we're gonna
do that
be there or be square come on by and
okay us take our butts kick our butts I
was trying to think of a thing your
focus in the eye I don't know make it
rhyme fight us Mortal Kombat 11 next
week we'll bring our a-game hope you'll
bring your a-game if you're worried
about not being good enough are you
worried about being too good
don't we're here just to have a good
time you show up have a good time get
yourself a fatality or two all right are
you uh I'm pressing the button to log in
this is gonna be fun because it's gonna
bring up the menu it's me don't worry
yet here sure that sweet persona jams
that's what I'm here for
I like X but uh I think it's got my
least favorite art style else wait what
I just kicked myself off my playstation
Oh were you doing something out there
it's fine we're good we're fine we're
fine we're doing it do it live on now
yes so I'm gonna pick Johnny Cage
because that's the obvious choice for me
okay
someone I was getting recommendations
what Leatherface I've never played
leather face that much so don't expect
good leather face but some variations I
remember I never use a list fisticuffs I
wanted to use originally and stunt
double I end up using later on but
yeah like it looks it's a good-looking
game but the art styles like very like
dark muted color palettes and I think
I'm not as into it
I like 9 is like very poppy like over
its like saturated colors and Elevens
kind of getting back to that so I think
I prefer that yeah honestly uh hi
Deadshot we're we're doing pretty good
how are you doing dad Chuckie and MK 11i
I'd be fine if we didn't though we'll be
asked not a big finish
I like the terminator option man the
interactions I almost forgot the
interactions are very good they've
gotten very good at like interactions
with the characters this is a very
different playing game from 9 I get the
dang
Michael Myers some people are saying
that be cool pretty cool that's the one
thing I remember about this goddammit
you know your Johnny Cage that's that's
a bad line doesn't represent Johnny Cage
as a whole we're in a better place now
oh I see your uppercut reaches further
than mine he's got really slow moves
remember I can do there's a kick oh that
one that's the kick
looking good we just die really quick
yeah I've been hearing a lot because a
terminator or spawn I like the idea of
ash I you - that's that's what I'm kind
of looking for sorry I'm messing a whole
bunch of stuff up - oh yeah oh I gotta
get an x-ray going I need to I need to
get my mind right what am i doing oh no
well I got a look at the fatality not an
easy fatality yeah well let's see
clothes see Ford back down should have
Leon an MK 11 like Leon Leon Scott
Kennedy
no Johnny no they did the thing with her
tongue
that was a heck of a sound that that man
made all right let's pick a new fighter
I'm into it
all right well so good we got a whole
bunch of the combat kids yeah which
means that I can double down on my cage
I'll do a the unfortunate combat kid
that they're not making him to which is
coming Jim I like to see him come back
yeah he's really cool but I'm glad that
Cassie's there I like Cassie
yeah she's good pit yeah yeah yeah oh I
know exactly what fatality I'm gonna do
too if I if I win oh I know I'm you're
gonna do it's it's it's the it's one of
my favorites
it's so good see the chronic of fatality
and impale of it I haven't yeah I did I
saw it got leaked on a YouTube oh man
it's pretty pretty brutal
those early copies getting out I know
it's like all there on YouTube already
I'm kind of bummed they weren't able to
keep Ashly Burch for Cassie yeah an
invoice actually sounds fine though it's
just sort of like oh that's our car boo
yikes I love you know how to play Cassie
I do not if I can jam it's all good
that's a meaty sound pistol shot really
yes
ah I think it's also a nine - but in the
background there's always just somebody
fighting blaze yeah in the background
I think it's blaze right I think so Wow
you can see that in like nine and you
can see in this one too and they don't
have the pit I think as a stage in
eleven right or at least we haven't seen
that I don't think we've seen it if it
is but hopefully they bring it at yeah
that's ectasia I thought this one back -
they did that this was added in the
excel update okay that was the second
round right yeah yeah yeah you got me
you got me good I was not playing
character I knew how to play it's all
good
oh no I do I not have it on I'm sorry I
don't have it unlocked that's okay uh
that's weird cuz I've definitely done it
sorry uh for town back forward
that's fine that's okay I'm sorry man I
don't know how I didn't have an unlock
cuz I've done it just say you're
difficult oh maybe it's because I'm on
my profile because it doesn't have my
save file because it maybe it's pulling
the information from what I have that
might make sense that's right it's fine
it's fine yeah weird I'm like wait a
minute I should have that I mean I would
go in like sign out and then sign in as
a guest but if I don't know if it's
worth it at this point so much Aaron
black are you good with Aaron
I'm not too good with him but I can I
can I can mess around with it and see
what there is to see I'm all picture oh
don't mention trimmer and I don't have a
play tremor so I like this bounty hunter
offer because it looks like something
that a feeble enemy would wear yeah I'm
pretty sure I did gunslinger all the
time so I'm like oh yeah six shooters
alright big stage
take it to the the the market I'll throw
that that old lady arrived i market
market sounds good yeah yeah
Goro Quan she would be cool it's really
weird that they keep leaving like Shiva
and gore out of things well I think our
own and X yeah there's pre-orders he was
your Shao Kahn I think it's cool they
put Scarlett in 11 because she was only
ever in 9 and she was only DLC so now
she's like a part of the game like
properly more and I like that a lot
yeah oh yeah oh yeah throw the dust in
his eyes pockets and pockets and got you
some Jonathan Sakura moves
I employ much Aaron black but I know
people like him a lot
I imagine he's gonna be a popular one on
the Internet
Sammy I'm excited to try Milan and 11
because I think I missed the boat on him
in this one people that's like it was
like cone Jin and Aaron black we're like
all people played I need to get back
into how to help certain TX moves work
or me to burn lawyers work so I just did
that slide and I'm like oh yeah you can
shoot after that oh no
look at that sweat
oh that sweat tag yeah the sweat real
gross looking it's not normal that's
nice it's not how sweat looks no one has
it just doesn't bubble and stay on your
skin like that it's real gross looking
dang oh you're not dude okay that's okay
come back we're fine no this is okay I'm
trying to put up a fight at least oh
you're trying to know what the meter
burn button is Richards right bumper
this is crazy right oh no do it again
bring it around town oh that's a good
kick
I like that kick a lot nah dang it's got
your name on it this is a really cool
x-ray move oh yeah I really like his uh
his fatal blow in 11 yeah it was so
messed up that should be like normal for
you though cuz you're made out of rocks
yeah I feel like that shouldn't affect
me this this would this would empower
the man should make him stronger than
ever before
I didn't go into my gun stance at all I
just remembered his his whole thing is
he has a gun stance with that variation
now we're gonna go for another 15
minutes I'd say all right sounds good we
should I'm a dude I'm into Jason
oh I'll bet you I'll do the one that
just makes him Baraka sounds like a plan
um it's a cool place The Cove the cove
with the K with a K of course the air
black is an MK 11 he looks pretty good
it is kind of a weird fatality
Oh none of these characters talk
also when is NetherRealm just gonna make
the flippin monster fighting I know
please do like I need it oh man I'm I'm
getting live though I'm feeling kind of
like I'm getting kind of like I feel I
feel sad because I realize that our
Mortal Kombat journey is coming to an
end
yeah we've done them all man starting to
think about that I'm like a Tang the one
we when we send this off we've
definitely I'll do the scorpion sub-zero
fight on the pit like it's gonna be a
thing
I just realized that I picked the
different variation from the one that I
was hoping for I was like Oh where's my
machete at I can't be any of my machete
moves and I realize that I picked
unstoppable instead of the slasher one
all right finish me I'm on it doing it
we got here kill for mother is sleeping
bag both are very good oh do you want
I've got I got three free easy
fatalities on my account because iris -
this is basically restarting it so I
might just do an easy one
or not never mind it's just anyone do it
in another room I should have look
anyway that's my vitality where I just
kick him in the in the face and I walk
away botched it again
it's your boy the the one who chokes
don't hate me for this but the DC one
was my favorite hey would never hate
anyone for Sangwan oh hey Trey yeah yeah
there's some good things about it I'm
gonna do Kay no because he's a gross boy
I think a yellow one
Shh
oh yeah I keep forgetting have to pick
the stage cuz uh I'm not used to that
you'd normally just thought it up just
to go this is like the first game that I
think like made you do it
yeah yeah let's do the crossroads with
the K sounds like a good plan to me
howdy got cheese she do Kung Lao Liu
Kang again at some point - oh sure
I also realize that we go on we've got
ten minutes left dang
that's the grab okay
I need to like make a comeback here so
I'm just gonna do this really quick
dang so the key no he's got some real
good like things in his toolset I'm
really in order who's your favorite MK
character Johnny Cage without a doubt
well you know I looking at Molina now -
I kind of like I'm gonna kind of Miss
that Molina's dang kiddos got me
quino's got some things down forward
down back
oh i remembers further one was really
easy to do could you do it from
fullscreen Thanks yikes indeed guys play
Street Fighter 5 Street Fighter 5 is is
a fun game it's come a long way but it's
not it's not it's not my favorite
fighting game right now but I like it
every now and then see who else we got
here who could we do we want to do Kung
Lao Liu Liu Kang sure and then we'll do
scorpion sub-zero I pick uh kinda well
yeah flame fist Dragon Fire do lists
yeah that sounds like that's where I
want to be oh man
the best skin in the game I'm into it
we stream MK 11 on day one ah I feel
like we should be I know that we're
doing community focused stream of it on
front definitely you and me will
definitely be here on Friday and Friday
for community stream but other than that
if not somebody will definitely stream
it when we're allowed to which would
either be I guess Tuesday when it comes
out or if for whatever reason we get it
early and are allowed to stream on
Monday and we'll find out but believe
that we'll be bringing that hot MORTAL
KOMBAT content with a Kade to you
whenever we can your favorite open-world
game right now
I don't familiar plane an open-world
game right now all right now Yakuza go
with the default cut those fireballs
still yoga Rooney's I can't find my
bicycle kick it's getting me
Oh No I thought that it would reach what
am i doing well hold it throw that whole
engine at you whoa wait whoa like Ron
get that timing star citizen star
citizen is a heck of a thing yeah I'm
curious to see where it goes or like
when that when they're officially like
star citizen is out like what what state
it's in oh well played I was waiting for
him like that
the interactable Scott to go fire sale
all interactivity must go one for
everyone
oh you're wiping the floor of me now
Luke he's pretty alright in this one
I don't play him much but he's now yeah
doesn't cool for tricks
Ferno sure okay
nice we've done it
that's not where that goes
that's definitely not where that goes
actually no it is kind of where it goes
you put it back where you got it from
yeah
characters are way too shiny I agree
yeah there's some some real shiny
glossiness too too much I definitely
like how much they've done that back for
11 all right so this is the scorpion the
finest scorpion arrow who do you want uh
who do you want I'm good either way
all right I like all right sub-zero it
is I would do mortal kombat one
throwback costumes so we have we do
let's do it
take it to the pit yeah do it up bring
it back full circle yeah I'm gonna do
Grand Master all right that this is is
it the last one of Mortal Kombat 10
before 11:00 happens after that no one's
a lot of play Mortal Kombat Mortal
Kombat 10 is cancelled after this anselm
dragged him sub-zero
oh now we're back in it now I am NOT in
it
sorry just got you gotta get that that
download first then everything will be
okay
I found the throw button who thought
mine would go I see you also use your
teleport move why you tonight jump out
from behind my no do it teleport I dare
you
teleport know what God do that woo
I was like this is gonna be fine this is
holy okay
whoo you know that there's only one way
that could played out no sub-zero okay
all right see this is how it should go
he is down to the last round and then
we're both feeling a lot of pressure
it's totally fine I'm not I'm not
nervous or shaking or anything oh that
didn't hit I thought that connected to
Jesus I did the I did the blog
I know well played it's happened do we
do we have the it's okay but we can we
can do let's hold on
easy fatality let's just make sure it's
locked in we'll do the classic head rip
on the classic stage with the classic
skins what the classic character is just
everything all together that's a really
good final match yeah I feel like we've
all grown as fans of Mortal Kombat and
his people and I'm looking forward to
playing Mortal Kombat 11 with all of you
guys looking forward to playing Mortal
Kombat 11 with you John Luke but yeah so
I was gonna do the uppercut little
spikes but because we didn't have it I
know the input I just went with the
classic one but that's okay mm-hmm
because we've done it played all the
Mortal Kombat games everyone we've we've
made it we made it we've done it did it
I'm proud of us me too
but if you guys enjoyed what you saw you
should definitely be sure to subscribe
to the channel and don't miss a single
stream we do we stream every single
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific hmm we're
here for you early game play dump
gameplay gameplay in general all that
gameplay just hanging out with you guys
I'm having a good time and that's what
we're here about yeah look forward next
week I'm sure we'll do a Mortal Kombat
screen do you not me it's literally us
maybe but other people will do one when
the game when we're able to stream it
but on next Friday we will do a
community Friday where we'll play Mortal
Kombat against you guys yeah and people
asking if we're gonna be playing days
gone I'm sure we'll play days gone at
some yeah that comes out next week right
we can't we can't ignore that game at
all it's also very big yeah we'll do
that
mmm I'll be good look forward to it and
go again yeah have a good weekend
everyone don't be a fool stay in school
play not gonna rap a playoff is a play
Mortal Kombat get practice stop cuz
we're gonna bring the heat on Friday
next week we're playing scorpion we'll
play scorpions gonna be real hot stew be
real spicy be there goodbye everybody
right here goodbye
we